assalamu alaikum welcome to the deen
show
I'm with Hakim Archuleta he went from
surfing to doing all sorts of incredible
things he's into the prophetic tradition
of medicine and guess where he's at
right next to me Salaam alaikum
this is the now used to surf I did serve
Yahoo's actually in the 40s and the 50s
that I was surfing yeah well it's an ad
longboards a longboard
they had different boards than they have
no Meah actually is a Brazilian
jiu-jitsu practitioner many people many
people they end up really surfing for
the balance and many other they derive
good benefit in short yeah and and and I
think yeah I've always said and I
believe very much that it's a very
valuable practice teaches you not only
these things of balance and coordination
but and sensory awareness of what's
happening but teach you how to ride the
waves and you know everything in nature
and everything in life we could say we
look at it one way there's a wave you
know incarnations and and and ideas and
attitudes come and things would happen
in ways that they start somewhere and
then they grow into a bigger thing in
and make another wave comes and so I
know surfing you learn you learn to read
the wave so one of the things the
surfers say if they're together that's
outside meaning don't take this wave
there's one outside that's even better
hang on and then you make an effort you
paddle it's like shaking the tree you
paddle just enough to get to the right
place in the way and then you can stand
up and you let the weight carry you so
that's a deep wisdom that we can find to
many many things in life including
healing can you share with us that time
in your life when you were seeking to
know the purpose of life you believe in
the creator and then you asked them to
guide you so I'm very simple yet
profound and then you actually from
there you met it you actually met a
Muslim and who told you about Islam can
you share with us this experience you
had
they thankful to you and forgive me for
one Accord but it is and so when someone
simply explained to me is not was the
five Miller's and so forth this is
unique I mean so you didn't you were you
were you believed in a creator yes
higher power God Almighty and you didn't
go through any intermediary you just
prayed to God huh I just I would Prince
I was a musician at the time and I
actually would sing my prayers
so Oh God I Here I am whatever I just
make up whatever and spontaneously play
music with this but I would would ask
forgiveness for wanting more look
wanting more and then prayed that it
wasn't doing the same prayer for maybe
five days week something like that and
then I went to his dawa you could say
took about twenty minutes half hour
Wow it's amazing tell us I was looking
for it and I think this is something to
realize with people there are many many
people out there that are looking for
something like Islam but we have to
allow it to be something for them other
than just another world religion
something that's put them all off you
know a lot of people are put off by
rogue religions they make up atheists so
but it's it's helpful to realize that
inside everyone is this longing and this
desire to find something that's
fulfilling in terms of we could say in
terms of a belief system everybody in
your class says everybody worship
something look to worship you know my my
name is my sheikh my teacher in Morocco
he said don't don't talk to people about
Islam don't argue for you stand talk
about it just feed them and welcome miss
guests and I've seen that I when you
know after 9/11 around 9:00 9/11 before
9/11 I
I came back from Morocco and other
travels in the world and I I took up
this practice for myself personally up
feeding people and I would have a big
meal for maybe 25 35 people my kids were
you know patron they'd bite their
friends that weren't Muslims to have
these meals and we cook really good food
from it and feed them and I would
explain to people I'd say you know
you're I'm doing this feeding you and
we're coming together just because as
human beings we want this and it's
natural for us to just be together with
each other eat together be appreciative
and thankful for it well we wouldn't
talk about his Saud they knew we were
Muslims like family and we'd go up and
pray when you know but there was no over
you know discussion about Islamic when
9/11 happened following 9/11 I started
getting phone calls for people from
people who come to those dinners and
they'd say to me I came you know I want
to come to dinner on Sunday but could I
come a little earlier because I'd like
to talk to you about something some
things nine people became Muslim
Wow and all we did he said oh we never
talked about all what we did was feed
him and all he did was observe all the
way we work together and so it's a
really natural organic kind of thing
that took place do you see a big
difference from when you were coming up
but again you know it's like one of the
historians famous asourian said this
this period of time is unique in human
in human history that we really people
have this idea that they can live
without a religion without some sort of
body of teaching that they can call
their religion and their the way in
which they worship God together so it's
a new thing and you know it's a it's an
example of them of the kind of the way
in which we're kind of bereft in the
present world their present time and how
we do without so much we realize is
essential to our nature so yeah and you
know you know I follow what Imam
al-ghazali said which is you know the
Atheist somewhere inside knows and
believes in God because they came from
the spirit and
that common spirit in which God has said
to them Allah said to them
elastic barbacoa am I not your Lord and
they answered affirmatively yes and
based on that when I you know I have I
have no arguments with the atheists I
have no discussion or the evidence I
don't have nothing to prove I'd simply
like to say look believe me whether you
believe me or not
you believe in God whether you know it
or not
you tell them head on head on I'm
kidding sometimes they get really angry
that's like saying who are you kidding
exactly you believe in God don't tell me
I know you've got a whole discussion you
know I've heard it many times I'm not
interested believe me you believe in God
last time I said that the man whose
veins went out in his neck and his face
got red but yeah you know I don't see
the point of getting into a discussion
about it because you know my discussion
my words you know not nearly as strong
as God's evidence you know someone said
if you don't you know not believing in
God is like is like or proof trying to
prove the existence of God is like
trying to prove the existence of the Sun
in the sky you know I mean duh the kind
of obvious yeah so yeah yeah it's a
different thing knows and there's a lot
of this sort of yeah a lot of new stuff
coming up I don't use up a lot of kind
of extremist atheist I guess to the
proud and really proud I'm an atheist am
i proud of it trying to convert us to
atheism we're gonna die remember to
someone saying well you know if you're
atheist at least you have the beginning
of the whole principle of Islam which is
that Allah there is no God except Allah
except the absolute reality which is not
a God and I used to when I became a
convert I loved the the principle that I
was not coming becoming a part of a
world religion I was becoming becoming a
part and joining something was much more
essential and true on a very basic
basic real level that dates it's the
path for us as human beings
quite simply nothing more yeah so not
another organization with all their sort
of details and you know that takes place
- in Islam but he was part of if
something comes to naturally forth from
it as part of our fifth or our first
nature we're gonna go ahead and take a
break and we'll be right back with more
I got some more questions to ask our
special guests here don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
subscribe right now
so now Lacko and welcome back to the
Dean show now when you did accept Islam
and I usually you know like to explain
to you know not yet Muslims out there
the people our brothers and sisters
humanity because and we think Islam you
think something foreign something error
something from Arabia but some is LA was
something that Jesus did Moses did
Abraham did they all submitted their
will to the crater you know alone pure
monotheism yes and did you get a lot of
backlash now from your family friends
when you did accept Islam friends at
that time as I was in Berkeley a lot of
friends they was there I was there a
ransom on your head no a lot of my
friends thought just thought I'd lost it
got crazy
maybe people at that time in Berkeley
this is 60s in Berkeley so they were
examining all kinds of things yoga and
Buddhism Eastern religions etc etc etc
and in that in that setup and what we
were investigating all sorts of things
aslam came up but Islam kind of you know
like I said when I met the Muslim
explained what it was it was you know it
kind of stuck with few of us and a lot
of my friends that at that time when
when I became Muslim there were two
other friends of mine in Berkeley that
men became Muslims at the same time and
they all kind of felt we were crazy they
were artists and you know poets and
things like that and but the interesting
thing is a lot of those people
eventually through the years there were
six more people from our kind of
community of friends they ended up
becoming Muslims eventually through the
years so it was kind of interesting it
just took them a little longer to get to
that yeah but we were looking at all
sorts of things at that time in Berkeley
all sorts of options possibilities
because basically a lot of what happened
at that time in the 60s was a really
healthy dissatisfaction not much life in
it so you know we were looking at all
these things at that time and and for a
lot of people Islam you know a lot of
people became Muslim eventually
you know in time you know just comparing
it I remember going to being part of
some some radio programs or made your TV
in which you know that we discuss that
we'd have on the tee on the panel we'd
have we'd have Muslim isawful
representing Islam and a Christian and a
Jew and a Buddhist and a new-age person
and maybe discuss I remember when
program we're discussing angels and the
it was a full you know along half hour
and 45 minute program something like
that and they all had the things to say
about angels and then I realized at some
point they had not much more to say and
I realized as a Muslim I had a lot more
to say I could go on and on and on about
it and that's one of the things that I
found really remarkable when I did
become Muslim is the the vast knowledge
of wisdom the kind of sea of knowledge
and kind of in just information beasts
but their knowledge that backed up tell
us you shared yesterday it's a story
that you had you know because I think
this is very important for anyone out
there to do you know in a state of
confusion that many people are in you
know they might have the biggest house
is the biggest car is they got money
suicides on the rise even amongst teens
you know trauma you know and we've been
affected by it but something just as
simple as what you did you asked you
know God alone you know you didn't you
didn't go through anyone out there and
you mentioned that you passed us along
to a lady shortly while after you saw
her hijab yeah yeah I could tell that
story I mean actually she was a patient
of mine
and she come to me with emotional
problems and some physical problems and
we did some work for a period of time
and she overcame her physical problems
and and emotional problems she was a lot
better and then one day she came to me
after she'd been well for a while she
came back he said you know I've come to
this place in my life and I considered
it a continuation of her being well and
getting healthy again and she said I
feel the need for worship in my life and
I could have said to her as opposed am I
sure to say I could have said well you
should look at your song because that's
what I do and so you know but I felt
some level that wasn't quite ethical I
was I was in a little confusion not sir
I should say that or not but I decided
not to say I'd rather I said well you
know you could do something that I know
that some people do which is you know
get up before dawn and find a place
where you can sit in reflection and and
and just be with yourself and be with
you know whatever the ask reality
reality that you find yourself and in
this this period of time in life itself
ask that reality to show you
signs of guidance of some kind so it's
come soon see it comes from deep within
you it comes to you in your world and
and she said well try that thanks for
the advice and I left her and then two
or three months later I ran into her on
the street pursuing a job and she said
yeah I did what she said thank you so
much because I did that and I asked
reality what I should do for guidance in
worship and she said everywhere I turned
that day the message Islam that's the
beautiful thing because the Creator that
happens in earth that's the ultimate
reality the one who created everything
and you when you ask God Almighty alone
for guidance
he will facilitate away but it's
surprising you don't see many people
doing that basic step
you know seeking out the purpose of life
why we're here why we've been created
some people do some people don't you
know some people are but again like I
said it's it's valuable to know that
somewhere inside people are thinking
that I mean people also give up on the
unfortunate yeah and they just shut down
turn it all off and they stop that
seeking but even those people sometimes
inside there's that spark you know
because they've come you know Quran says
we all come from Allah and return to
Allah yes and what happens in this life
is you know this is the zone of action
this is the time we have a chance to to
declare you're Muslim or to do good
actions bad acts all these things have
actually take place it in the next life
the meanings of these actions will
become manifest so you know deep inside
even and the true nature our true nature
people this is something as valuable and
feminist counseling and do a lot of
counseling but so-called psychological
work depression anxiety and things like
that it for these people is valuable to
know that inside them or our lack of
confidence in the world and they're
beaten down by society you know poor
people and socially kind of
disenfranchised and so forth and it's
awful for those people to do to connect
with their true nature to and help that
and then recognize it inside these
people I mean I work seeing people who
come out of Prisons just the most
outward it the most difficult kind of
people and make an axe if they can
access this true nature inside there is
compassion the inclination for
compassion in there for love and
goodness so that's something to keep in
mind with it with the most difficult
people sometimes even was Tanisha was
right back with more don't give up
Testament don't give up spark what's
already inside of you
we want to bring it out we'll be right
back with more Hannity show don't owe
any where subscribe right now
back here on the Dean show for my
special guests and what advice now
before we conclude would you give from
your experience you also now deal with
the prophetic medicine helping people
with their help with their nutrition we
see that it's astonishing
you know statistics one is that 50% of
people living today will have cancer one
in four will die from it
ninety-five percent chronic diseases are
by the food choices that people are
making you know obesity is on the rise
of endemic and kids are not expected to
live there their parent this is a matter
that needs to be taken seriously you've
been around you you've been dealing with
these things give us some tips whatever
was going on in one's life whether it's
emotional difficulties physical
difficulties whatever it might be that
seems to be obstacles yeah like you said
don't give up you know I mean it's said
the the possibilities are enormous for
healing what we experienced and what
we've experienced and the difficulties
that we've come that we find ourselves
with is not a sentence you know by a
lost generosity you know I've seen for
example I worked with cancer people for
a long time there is no known cancer
that was not sort of the person overcame
we could say healed some a lot of people
say well in remission whatever you know
there's no there's no cancer knowing
that people did not have victory over
and this is true for all sorts of
illnesses and in terms of emotional
things and depression and so called one
of the things it just bothers me so
being schizophrenic they're told by
psychiatrists well this is something
you'll have for a year lie all like
you're live and you don't have to take
medication and that's just not true you
know statistically you know two thirds
of those people recover two thirds of
people come back to a normal functional
life and this is so this is just the
same thing is true for all the obstacles
and difficulties the more obstacles in
fact truth in matter is this indeed
I'm here in this and listen carefully
anyone listening then all the
difficulties we have our gifts for us
when we can recognize them when we can
understand them when we can make use of
them and assimilate them and transmute
them from difficulties and obstacles
into resources for wisdom and compassion
ourselves we're designed to do that by
allows design in us and that's what real
hearing is about that's what real
spiritual progress needs spiritual paths
wasn't all that difficult all the slings
and arrows of life in turning those
around and using those things as
resources so that we can be more
compassion for others who have similar
problems and the difficulties they're
going through or similar to our own and
and really nothing more valuable for us
in terms of healing in terms of being in
this world than serving other people and
helping them out of their difficulties
by alone you know some come in
quarantine gates these cutting things
say thank you for spending time with us
you're welcome we started with a piece a
very very powerful greeting that we
agree with and people are searching for
it and he's turning to the D shorter
listen to us okay nobody can find it
like you know we're saying it and don't
give up we'll see you next time tune in
every week to the D show subscribe if
you haven't already until next time
Salaam alaikum peace be with you
subscribe right now
you